NARRATOR: To get a firsthand
look into this continued search
for extraterrestrial
life, in March of 2016,
researcher and publisher
Giorgio Tsoukalos
traveled to the
Allen Telescope Array
in Hat Creek California,
where he met with the director
for SETI research, Seth Shostak.
This is truly amazing.
What can you tell
me about this place?
Well, this place
is an observatory,
but it's a radio observatory.
So these things around
us, these 42 antennas,
they pick up radio waves.
And we're trying to pick up very
special sort of radio waves,
namely some that would tell
us somebody's out there.
By having lots of
these dishes here,
we can look at more
of the sky at once.
We can look at multiple
star systems at once.
Why radio waves?
What's so significant
about radio waves?
SETH SHOSTAK: Radio waves
go at the speed of light.
And they also, by the way, go
through all the gas and dust
that's between the stars.
So you know, if you
want to communicate
from one part of the
galaxy to another,
radio waves are a
great way to do it.
So the way this works is
actually kind of simple.
I mean, the cosmic radio static,
it comes in from the sky,
and it bounces off that
big reflector there,
that first one.
OK, that's a mirror
for radio waves.
And that redirects them to this
secondary reflector on the end,
on the nose there.
And then they're directed to
the receiver, and that's inside.
That information goes
through a fiber optic
over to the control room.
So this is where the data
coming through the fiber optic
kind of ends up, after
it's been processed
in a display like this.
And what are we
looking at right here?
So we're looking,
in this case, at three
star systems at once, OK.
So that speeds up the search.
It also allows us to
determine whether we're really
seeing ET or just interference.
The data from one of
these star systems
is being displayed on this
part of the screen here.
This is called a waterfall plot.
That, can you see that line of--
This right here, yes.
--brighter dots there?
Yeah, that's a slightly more
static at that frequency
slowly going down the dot.
That's the kind of
thing we're looking for.
So then if this here
were an actual ET signal,
how would it
differentiate itself?
Would it be a bit thicker, a bit
more pronounced, a bit longer?
Or what are you looking for?
It could be all
of those things.
So what you'd do is when
you find a signal like this,
you make a test.
You'll just move the
antennas a little bit
and see if the signal
goes away, and then
point it back at the star
and see if it comes back.
You'd say, well, that's
looking promising.
You do that again, go
off, go on, go off, go on.
If you do that five or 10
times, you start to get excited.
I hope that that day
will come very soon.